the united states is stepping up its
military support for ukraine a moment
ago u.s president joe biden announced a
new tranche of military support worth
800 million dollars for keefe this
latest package is in addition to
billions of dollars of military
equipment washington already
has given to ukraine's government
president biden said the package would
contain heavy weaponry that the
government in ukraine says it
desperately needs today i'm announcing
another 800 million dollars to further
augment ukraine's ability to fight in
the east in the donbass region
this package includes heavy artillery
weapons
dozens of howitzers and 144 000 rounds
of ammunition to go with those howitzers
it also includes more tactical drones
all right like to turn now to michael
kimmich a historian and former u.s state
department expert on russia and ukraine
during the obama administration a very
warm welcome to dw news sir thank you
for taking out the time to meet with us
um the we just heard president biden
just moments ago announced this new 800.
800 million dollars rather of military
aid package for ukraine can you outline
for us the significance of this amount
well it's a substantial amount of money
and what's i think more significant than
the immediate sum is that it's a part of
a continuum of aid
uh flowing from the united states and
also from many european countries uh
toward ukraine and it's a demonstration
in a different sense of of resolve that
there's a strong and deepening
commitment to ukraine on the part of the
united states and its transatlantic
partners
now as you know there is this offensive
that russia has unleashed in the east of
the country
we heard president biden say that
they want the us wants the weapons to go
to the front line immediately but
realistically how quickly can they get
there
well i think it can be really quite
quick i think there's a way in which uh
you know the outside suppliers military
suppliers of ukraine have been learning
how to
how to transmit these weapons to the
front and it's not a secret where the
russians are at the moment and where the
russians are going to strike it's very
very clear so you know i think that the
methods are there
and the destination is really not
ambiguous so i think it will come very
quickly to ukraine
and speaking about the ukrainian army
what chance do they have to fend off
this offensive
it's truly anybody's guess in terms of
the day-to-day military uh outcomes
they've so far done very very well in
the north but the terrain is going to be
more difficult for them in the south
it's more wide open
and the russians are changing tactics
and will likely be i think more
successful than they were in the north
but whether they can really overcome
ukraine in the south and the east
i think it's unlikely
and what's your assessment sir in terms
of this support that the u.s is
providing ukraine is it
sustainable
i think it's certainly sustainable you
see enormous will in congress that's
really where the money is coming from
it's one of the few issues on which
republicans and democrats really agree
uh in washington and i think that the
white house is very happy to have this
congressional support so i think that
there's no way that this military aid is
going to stop or slow down
in the short to medium term
a very striking comment that the
president made as well is regarding the
u.s banning russian-affiliated ships
from u.s ports how significant is that
well i don't know if in and of itself
it's hugely significant i don't think
there's a big trading relationship
between russia and the united states in
either direction but it's the slow
tightening of the noose around the
russian economy
and the gradual abrupt and gradual
isolation
of the russian economy and so as part of
this larger pattern
russia just sees markets and options
closing off
and that will over quite a long period
of time that will have a dramatic effect
on on the russian economy
michael kimmich historian and expert on
russia and ukraine sir thank you for
taking our questions greatly appreciate
it
thank you for having me
u.s president joe biden also said there
is quote no evidence that mariupol has
fallen to russia it comes after moscow
tried to claim victory there saying
russian forces have successfully
liberated the port city in southeastern
ukraine the azov style steel plant is
the last place in mariupol still in
ukrainian hands it's believed some 2 000
soldiers and around a thousand civilians
are sheltering there kiev is demanding
moscow open a humanitarian corridor to
let civilians leave
president putin called off plans to
storm the complex instead in a televised
meeting he told his defense minister to
completely seal off the area our report
now on the steel plant that has become a
symbol of ukrainian resistance
[Applause]
the vast azov style steel plant
seen here in footage from russian state
television is the last part of mariopol
and ukrainian control after nearly two
months of heavy fighting
with much of the strategic port in ruins
president putin's claimed victory in the
city
and told his defence minister to seal
off its defenders in their last
stronghold
[Applause]
i consider the proposed storming of the
industrial area pointless
i order to abort it
there is no need to climb into these
catacombs and crawl underground through
these industrial facilities
block off this industrial area so that
not even a fly can get through
ukrainian authorities have urged moscow
to open humanitarian corridors to allow
those sheltering in the heavily
bombarded azostal plant to flee
these pictures provided by the plant's
defenders show some of the hundreds of
civilians said to be sheltering in
bunkers below the steelworks
but previous efforts to organize
evacuations from mario paul have had
little success on wednesday only four
buses carrying evacuees managed to leave
the city through a humanitarian corridor
some one hundred thousand residents are
thought to still be living among the
ruins
those now blockaded in the azov style
steel plant may well face the choice
between starvation or surrender
dr aglaya snetkov is an expert on
russia's foreign and security policy and
i asked her what she thinks is behind
president putin's decision not to storm
the steel plant in mariupol
and i think effectively it's a
recognition that to storm it will be
very difficult for the russians and that
they would sustain heavy losses and that
it will take a long time so i would go
along with sort of putting um
his own assessment that essentially it's
not effective for the russian troops to
storm it lose a lot of manpower and
actually it is more effective from the
point of view of the russian troops to
block continue the blockade because
there are the ukrainians are unable to
resupply um their troops in
the um still um
exhaustion plant and therefore you know
it will be a matter of time till the
blockade effectively
um creates a situation where the
fighters will have to come out and the
russians would like to preserve their
troops they would like to move them to
dambass to link them up with their
troops in luhansk and daniels and
therefore effectively they're not
prepared to lose them
over the
the current blockade of azostal so what
happens next now what does victory look
like for the russians
i think that's sort of the you know
million dollar question we don't know
um i think commentators and i would
agree with the assessments to say that
in some ways britain can turn anything
into victory the russian public although
on the whole seems to be supporting the
war they don't seem to have a good idea
as to what a victory looks like and in
that respect i think it is down to putin
and what he wants to see as a victory
and i think that's why the situation is
so dangerous because we simply don't
know
what is enough for putin you know is a
victory over mariopol enough
is the taking over of all of the luhansk
daniels oblast
a victory is it pushing further into the
parts of eastern ukraine is it getting a
negotiation
between himself and zelensky we don't
know at this stage what is sufficient
and i think that is why
it is very dangerous
as the situation develops
dr aglaya snetkoff expert on russia's
foreign and security policy thank you
very much for taking our questions thank
you